hey you guys it's max max tech we just
got the brand new Samsung Galaxy Tab s6
in and today we're gonna be comparing it
with Apple's 11 inch iPad pro you guys
may have seen my galaxy s5 evideos and I
was really impressed with that tablet
Samsung did a fantastic job but there
was one thing that kept me from
recommending it to most people who like
to buy a tablet every to say two to
three years and that was the processor
inside of it now here the tab s6 is
going to fix that now right out of the
gate we see a couple differences in the
Box first off the tab s6 comes with an S
Pen you don't have to purchase it
separately but we'll be talking about
that in just a bit when we compare it to
the Apple pencil but second is the
charger unfortunately the tab s6 does
not come with that new amazing 25 watt
Samsung charger that comes with a note
10 plus but instead the same 15 watt
charger that has a standard USB here and
a USB type-c on the other end whereas
the iPad pro comes with an 18 watt USB
type-c charger the same one that we
expect in the new upcoming iPhones the
Essex's battery is slightly smaller so
charging time should be fairly similar
as you guys can see they look quite
similar from the top but that does
change once we pick it up the top s6 is
super thin and super lightweight you
definitely feel it in the hands compared
to the iPad pro you may have also
noticed that there is a decent size
difference between the two even though
the specs don't make it seem like there
is so the iPad is actually a little bit
taller and quite a bit wider because of
different display aspect ratio which
we'll talk about in just a bit
both of these high-end tablets do use
USB type-c neither of them have a
headphone jack unfortunately and both of
them also do have quad speaker so two at
the bottom and two at the top now the
iPad has its magnetic connector for the
Apple pencil here on the side whereas
the new tab s6 actually puts it on the
back over here let's test it out
essentially it actually just magnetized
right here not in that slot and the
pencil does move around quite a bit the
magnets actually up here as you guys can
tell so it's not doesn't seem as a
secure or a strong of a connection
compared to the iPad now the next major
difference is authentication the tab s6
gives you a variety of different options
of what most people are going to be
using is the fingerprint authentication
where this new tab s6 actually uses an
optical and display fingerprint scanner
unlike their flagship phones that use an
ultrasonic sensor what we've seen with
the oneplus phones is the the optical
ones actually we're quicker and they're
a bit more reliable okay not bad
wow that is definitely faster than on
the s10 phones and on the note 10 as
well but of course the iPad pro uses
face ID as you guys could see it already
unlocked before I swiped and what the
iPad you can hold it any direction I can
hold it sideways upside down as long as
you're not blocking the sensor here it
will work it works fast very secure and
very reliable so I would say that face
ID is better than having to put your
fingerprint on there as you guys can see
it works really well
now let's go ahead and compare the
displace and the first thing that I have
to mention because it really just popped
out like crazy is the reflectivity the
iPad has much less reflections and the
screen looks dark or black even when
it's shut off whereas the tab s6 has a
ton of reflectivity and it picks up all
sorts of colors so brown from that kind
of wall bluish over here it is a massive
difference and along with that if we
pick it up and start looking from the
sides the screen is kind of wavy which
is very interesting almost like it's
made out of plastic which I don't think
it is I think it's glass now another big
difference is the aspect ratio so the
Samsung is actually a 16 by 10 display
not a sixteen by nine but the iPad is
actually a four by three so that means
that even though the specs 11 inch
versus 10 and a half those seem very
similar in the real world the iPad has a
lot more usable screen real estate the
next question is does the tap s6 put out
more light to battle that reflectivity
and the answer is and no not at all the
iPad is definitely quite a bit brighter
and when we max both of these out I'm
still seeing a bunch of reflections on
the tab
six where's the iPad has none whatsoever
because of that brighter display now as
far as the shift looking from the sides
the iPad does have a little bit more
brightness shift but because the display
is brighter even from the side it is
still brighter and looks better the
display resolutions and pixels per inch
are actually fairly similar so both
these displays look really good they're
very sharp but if we go and take a look
at a YouTube video there is a massive
difference in all sorts of things first
off just the quality because Android can
actually play back the vp9 codec we're
playing back at 1440p 60fps in compared
to 1080p and not only that we also get
HDR video playback with the tab s6
compared to just standard with the iPad
so with the tab s6 we see a lot more
detail better colors and better dynamic
range as well we have a lot more details
in the shadows and in the highlights of
course this is an OLED display so the
blacks are very deep pure black compared
to slightly grayish on the iPad and
overall if you like watching videos the
tab s6 will definitely be a better
experience the iPad pro screen does have
one trick up with sleeve one standout
key feature and that is promotion which
allows it to run at up to 120 Hertz
which gives it a super smooth motion
compared to the 60 Hertz but not only
that it can actually drop down to 60
Hertz or 30 or even 24 Hertz when you're
watching a video so will match up to
your content and that will allow it to
save battery life as well so here you
guys can see the differences between the
two as far as fluidity that is
definitely better on the iPad now with
that said let's jump into the Pens
and this promotion actually helps the
iPad out as well starting out with the
s-pen as you guys can see if I move
quickly there's quite a bit of delay
compared to the Apple pencil even moving
quickly there is no delay whatsoever and
now it's time to compare the speakers
both of these have quad speakers which
is great if you want to watch videos
listen to music we do have Dolby Atmos
turned on with the tab s6 and
to start out by listening to the iPad
pro which absolutely destroys all of the
other iPads that Apple makes let's go
ahead and try this out
[Music]
okay so we were not expecting that that
sounded good it definitely sounded good
had good volume but man the type of six
just smoked it like crazy now this is a
time that I would normally compare the
keyboards but unfortunately we are still
waiting for a tab s6 keyboard with that
new trackpad to come in so we'll be
doing a separate comparison on which one
of these tablets are a better laptop
replacement and they're going to cover
the keyboards that trackpad we're gonna
cover decks as well as other hardware
and soccer that we didn't in this video
so if you guys want to see that video
it's gonna be a great one make sure you
guys are subscribed that you guys have
those notifications enabled before we
talk about performance let's take a
quick look at the cameras we have a dual
system with the tab s6 so not only the
standard we also have this ultra wide
right here but we do not have a flash
which is weird for me because I would
think with the tablet you would use it
to scan documents maybe deposit checks
that kind of stuff and a flash
definitely comes in handy now with the
iPad we have that single camera so you
can't switch but we have that flash and
we also have a port remote but only for
the front here's a few shots for you
guys side by side let me know in the
comments section does the iPad do a
better job or does the tab s6 and also
let me know do you guys actually use
your tablets to take photos I definitely
want to hear your guys's opinions now
finally let's get into performance we
just ran a geek bench for test and as
you guys can see there is a pretty
substantial performance difference now
the tab at 6 is still really respectable
in its top of the line as far as
smartphones go it has a Qualcomm 855
processor but the a 12 X Bionic that's
in the iPad pro is on a whole nother
level
this is laptop like performance actually
beating out a fair number of laptops now
let's also go ahead and run Geekbench 5
because that was just released the tests
just finished and as you guys could see
the numbers are much lower it's kind of
odd to see the numbers this low but the
test has been updated here
yeah it's a pretty substantial
difference about 50% faster in single
core the iPad pro is and roughly 65 ish
percent faster in the multi-core score
now of course these are just benchmarks
and what I am wondering about is is
there actually a difference in the real
world and for that you guys should tune
in to our full detailed review after
we've been using the tab at 6 for a
while and along with that I want to plug
a couple other videos we might do a
performance comparison chasing some
different apps in a gaming comparison so
we can check out the difference in
graphics so make sure you guys are
subscribed and have those notifications
enabled and to finish off let's talk
about prices the iPad pro retails at
$800 for this 11 inch model and that is
with 64 gigabytes of storage of course
four gigs of RAM and no pen or anything
else included whereas the brand new tab
s6 starts off at six hundred and forty
nine dollars so $150 less and that's
actually what's a hundred and twenty
eight gigs of storage six gigs of ram
and with that s-pen included so right
off the get-go that gives you a much
better value but not only that with the
tab s6u we actually have a microSD
expansion slot that can support up to
one terabyte microSD cards now if you
spend a little bit more money for $730
this is the model we have with 256 gigs
of storage and also eight gigs of ram so
not that much more money and gives you
you know an extra bang for the buck
there but with the iPad you can't get a
128 gig set up you have to go straight
to the 256 and that cost an extra 150
dollars and no matter which
specification you want either just the
tablets by themselves or adding on a
keyboard or an Apple pencil
we're specking them all the way up the
tap s6 is definitely a better value but
of course there's some other things that
come into play such as software and
maybe depends so make sure you guys are
subscribed and you guys have
notifications enable so you guys don't
miss out on our video covering which one
of these is a better laptop replacement
and of course we're gonna have a couple
other videos as well that you guys are
gonna want to watch and if you want to
watch something else right now a couple
videos right there for you guys
this has been matched with max tech and
I will see you in the next video
[Music]